le cinéma pleins feux sur une nouvelle
star d'hollywood elle est un prénom
presque français et elle ne cesse de
grimper au box office vous l'avez
d'ailleurs peut-être vu déjà dans les
sorcières d'eastwick ou dans les
liaisons dangereuses elles étaient la
très belle madame de tourvel bref elle
s'appelle michel fait faire retenez bien
ce nom
on a toutes les chances de le voir
beaucoup dans les années 90 son dernier
film soucis et les baker boys sort
demain en france nicole corps nus tenant
de loi on savait qu'elles étaient belles
et bonnes comédiennes et maintenant elle
chante pas mal du tout
d'un point de vue
la nouvelle
s'il ne devient pas une star c'est que
comme chanteuse elle est peut-être bonne
mais elle ne l'est pas génial
à mon avis elle n'est pas très
ambitieuse allait surtout curieuse de la
vie elle préfère toucher à tout et
croquer la vie à belles dents en
multipliant les expériences elle est
découverte par deux frères pianiste un
peu ringard qui cherche partenaires
désespérément mais c'est zidane katché
alors elle fait exploser leur médiocrité
au cinéma ça se finit toujours bien et
moi comme les autres je n'y comprends
plus rien quand ça se passe mal dans ma
vie je me dis que c'est une ma faute
alors qu'en fait la vie souvent cruel il
faut traverser des épreuves très pénible
avant de voir le bout du tunnel et
inspiré que ça va se terminer par un
film réaliste et romantique à fond